warum zieht bremen nicht mit oder
verkünden sie jetzt hier das auch bremen
die pflicht zur maske einführt oder sind
sie falsch informiert bremen hat sich
auch dafür entschlossen die maske
pflicht einzuführen wir werden die
entsprechende rechtsverordnung ab
freitag verabschieden und dann wird sie
im antritt der masken pflicht zur
nächsten montag vor sehen wir haben das
erst intensiv diskutiert gehabt haben
eigentlich gedacht wir können noch
stärker auf freiwilligkeit setzt nach
dem vorsitz im bundesrat ein
flickenteppich gibt es keine insel sind
wir natürlich auch mit dabei
wichtig ist dass die menschen die klare
orientierung kriegen oder braucht man
sich unterschiedliche regelungen blatt
man hat aber gerade weil sie die
orientierung ansprechen so ein bisschen
das gefühl bei dieser entscheidung bund
länder einigen sich also darauf dass es
keine bundesweite regelung gibt dann
recht ein land vor sachsen dann zieht
das nächste nach dann kommen 23 weitere
das ist doch keine entscheidung auf
einer faktenbasis
das ist doch eher herdentrieb oder naja
eigentlich schon ja intensiv bei der
konferenz der ministerin sind mit der
kanzler diskutiert ich habe mich sehr
dafür eingesetzt dass wir schneller zur
nachricht dann sagen wir haben die
pflicht haben dann sind wir dann alle
masken aber schon vorhanden
dann wurde gesagt dringende empfehlung
ohne dringende empfehlung ist natürlich
schon ziemlich dicht dran einer pflicht
jetzt auch gewünscht dass man sich jetzt
vorher noch mal telefonisch auf eine
einheiten im jahr verständigt
aber der trend und die diskussion gehen
natürlich ebenso einer verpflichtung
warum weil doch auch die medizinischen
instanzen die fraglichen instanzen sich
schrittweise immer mehr dem angenähert
haben dass seine verpflichtung sinnvoll
ist wenn sie das lka vor vier wochen
gefragt hätten hätten sie noch die
antwort bekommen so eine verpflichtung
ist nicht sinnvoll da hat sie doch auch
die meinung der fachwelt ist selbert und
wir haben uns ein bisschen in bremen
umgeschaut heute da laufen noch recht
wenige menschen mit einer maske rum
jetzt soll sich das ja halt ändern wird
auch bei ihnen verpflichten wie sie
gerade gesagt haben
wie man will man das durchsetzen wer
kontrolliert das
also erstmal hatte sich um deutlich
verändert wir nun morgen das straßenbahn
gefahren war und für 80 prozent der
fahrgäste schon mit einer maske
gestern war das noch deutlich weniger
ich weiß nicht wie es sich heute in den
einzelhandelsgeschäften darstellen wird
auch ohne verpflichtung hinter der
anteil der menschen mit maske deutlich
zugenommen aber mit der verpflichtung ab
montag wird es natürlich schneller gehen
das umsetzen funktioniert im
wesentlichen so wenn die menschen wissen
dass es eine verpflichtung ist dann hält
sich der allergrößte teil wie auch die
meisten menschen ja wenn sie nach unten
an bestehen mit anderen nicht einfach so
da drüber gehen auch wenn gerade kein
polizist in der nähe ist oder weil sich
zu wissen ist es wichtig nicht nur noch
rote ampel zu gehen also ich setze
darauf dass der ganz große teil der
menschen die verpflichtung von sich aus
ein halten wird